we all naturally want to be winners and
so consequently a great many countries
are designed to reward winners these are
the countries that pay a good deal of
attention to optimizing the conditions
of life available to people who win in
such lands if one's a winner and falls
ill the hospitals are outstanding the
transport laid on for winners is
superlative if a housing for winners is
spacious light and uplifting and winner
children are educated in establishments
that resemble 5-star hotels of course in
such lands provisions for losers are not
quite so comfortable there isn't the
money left over so housing for losers
can be challenging transport for losers
is something of a humiliation and the
children of losers start to learn quite
young about their negligible status this
could all sound worrying but it tends
not to panic us very much for one
fundamental reason related to how the
human mind works most of us who
naturally assume that we will at some
point become winners you can see this
optimistic part of the brain in action
in our well observed proclivity for
playing the lottery
millions of us show an inclination to
believe that we will end up holding a
winning ticket
despite some pretty daunting odds the
chances of winning the UK lottery are 1
in 14 million but this often isn't
enough to put many of us off if we don't
play the lottery ourselves we may feel a
bit sorry for people who do we may smile
at their folly in getting statistics
quite so wrong but in the way we vote in
elections we may display a strikingly
similar mindset we too may cast our
votes for political parties determined
to reward a tiny subset of winners while
casting the fast majority of losers to a
less dignified end we would do well to
study statistics
the chances of starting a billion-dollar
company in the US the chances of earning
less than $200,000 per annum in the US
the chances of needing to depend on the
state for health housing transport or
welfare over a lifetime in the European
countries in short a degree of financial
fragility is the statistical norm being
a loser is the norm we are far more
likely to end up with a mediocre salary
with delicate health and vulnerability
to ill fortune than we are to end up
robust invulnerable winners and yet
still we insist on creating and
supporting winner countries here are 5
of the world's top winner countries
countries that go out of their way to
make the consequences of winning as
pleasant as possible in fifth place
Brazil fourth place India third place
China
second place UK first place at us there
are a few notable loser countries on our
planet they tend not to get the
limelight here is the list of the
world's top loser countries in fifth
place the Netherlands fourth Germany
third Switzerland second Norway first
Denmark in looser countries voters
graciously assume that they are and will
remain in losers and therefore they set
about trying to make their condition as
pleasant as possible
they make sure there is a public
transport system fit for losers they
want public housing fit for losers and
public schools fit for complete losers
in these countries for losers it can be
a bit awkward to be a winner
no one applauds you for driving a fancy
car money won't buy you schools any
better than the loser ones you might
even choose to go to a loser hospital of
your own accord and your taxes might be
quite high both countries for winners
and countries for losers have their
advantages
the question is whether we're voting for
societies that reflect our own
statistical realities by accepting that
we will almost certainly be and remain
losers we might be sad no doubt but we
may also be liberated to start a scheme
to live in societies that make the
consequences of failing a lot less
bitter we love bringing you these films
if you want to help us to keep bringing
you thoughtful content please consider
supporting us by visiting our shop at
the link on your screen now